[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale en 26 minutes tout de
suite les titres de ce mercredi 14
novembre
c'est l'une des solutions avancées pour
faire face à la désertification médicale
une maison de santé pluridisciplinaire a
ouvert ses portes à trappes depuis huit
mois
elle a été inaugurée officiellement hier
sur place 14 professionnels dont des
médecins généralistes sage femme ou
encore ostéopathe
la semaine dernière le secours
catholique dévoilait son rapport annuel
sur la pauvreté en france elle continue
de progresser notamment dans les
yvelines où les femmes sont
particulièrement concernés elle nous en
parlons avec notre invité françois paget
délégué départemental du secours
catholique
et puis le département de plus en plus
confrontés à des pics de crue ces
dernières années les pompiers des
yvelines se forment régulièrement à
gérer ce type de situation
elle nous avons pu suivre l'un de leurs
stages sur le stade d'eaux vives de
l'île de loisirs de cergy-pontoise
invite également à tout à l'heure
catherine arnaud vice président du
conseil départemental des yvelines on
parlera du lancement de la plateforme
jobs 78 la police nationale des yvelines
relance son appel à témoins aïssata elle
n'a pas donné de signe de vie depuis 10
mois sept trappistes de 18 ans est porté
disparu depuis le 26 janvier dernier est
les autorités précisent qu'elle est
susceptible de se trouver à marseille et
de mettre son intégrité physique en
danger si vous avez des informations
contactez le commissariat de trappes
attrapé justement elle est ouverte
depuis le mois de mars mais a été
inauguré officiellement ce mardi à 13
novembre la maison de santé du théâtre
est composé de quatorze professionnels
une opportunité pour la ville de
renforcer son nombre de médecins les
détails avec ce sujet de nicolas landry
un pôle médical de 285 mètres carrés
répartis sur 3 zones c'est la nouvelle
maison de santé du théâtre de trappes
médecins généralistes sages femmes
infirmières ostéopathe psychologue
orthophoniste un projet collectif et un
travail collaboratif
on parle on rencontre par nos échanges
ne fait pas d'eux
de savoir ce que fait ce que font les
autres et crétin va on a une orientation
beaucoup plus efficace ça doit partir
des professionnels et les professionnels
à partir du moment où ils ont un projet
que ce soit dans une maison de santé ou
par une coordination entre eux mais la
rs doit être capable de les accompagner
c'est aussi ça le dialogue entre tous
les professionnels de santé médecins
infirmières ostéopathe sages-femmes
psychologue qui permet une prise en
charge globale des patients et c'est ça
que nous voulons encourager coût total
de cette maison de santé près d'un
million d'euros avec un financement de
l' agence régionale de santé de l'ue rps
hauteur de 350 mille euros une
subvention de la région ile-de-france de
260 milles euros
ça correspond à une volonté de la région
la présidente de la région valérie
pécresse est bien de lutter contre les
déserts médicaux il y en ait ici dans
une ville qui est l'une des plus
carencée en termes de médecins
généralistes c'est donc naturellement il
est important de soutenir ce type de
structure et avec encore une fois un
montant très importante pour la ville de
trappes classé en zone d'intervention
prioritaire par la rs c'est une
opportunité d'augmenter l'offre de soins
sur la commune
cette maison de santé qui je viens
d'apprendre la maintenant représente 14
praticiens c'est un pôle essentiel pour
notre ville d'autres pièces vont être
aménagés pour pouvoir accueillir de
nouveaux spécialistes et des internes en
médecine dans cette nouvelle maison de
santé santé toujours avec de petites
bêtes véritable cauchemar pour les
enfants et parents les poux sont
toujours aussi présents dans les écoles
à mantes la jolie
un salon aux méthodes douces pour
éliminer pour les éliminer a vu le jour
en mai dernier le tout premier dans les
yvelines un reportage de marie lehn yapi
chinois la fage là c'est pour tout ça
lasse et des poufs partout ce n'est pas
un salon de coiffure ordinaire mais un
centre anti poux le concept bien des
états unis et connaît un grand succès en
espagne depuis deux ans ces centres
arrivent en france celui de
mantes-la-jolie a ses propres méthodes
c'est le premier en yvelines on
travaille avec aucun produit chimique
ont fait travailler un petit fabricant
et récoltant
d'hydrolats et d'huile qui se situe dans
la drôme des produits 100% naturels et
bio est une méthode artisanale
les clients restent le temps qu'il faut
pour s'assurer d'être entièrement
débarrasser une fois qu'on a retiré le
surplus des poux et les lentes on va
aller rechercher toutes les lans
restantes sur chaque cheveu et de
retirer à la main une par une ciao nice
a ouvert en mai dernier et a pour
objectif de se développer sous forme de
franchise la demande est là un pou
femelle peut pondre jusqu'à 10 l'an par
jour et déclenché l'invasion
c'est pas du tout une question d'hygiène
c'est un animal qui est notre compagnon
depuis toujours et c'est même titre que
la moustiques par exemple ça fait partie
de notre quotidien
en plus du traitement le centre n'oublie
pas de prodiguer des conseils pour ne
jamais voir revenir ses clients je lis à
repart avec le sourire cela faisait un
an qu'elle essayait de s'en débarrasser
j'en avais j'en ai plus et après ma vie
une petite net
compter entre 30 et 60 14 euros selon la
longueur des cheveux pour un traitement
en une fois et un contrôle la semaine
suivante le 7 novembre le secours
catholique caritas france dévoilé son
rapport pauvreté 2018 le constat la
précarité progressent et surtout chez
les femmes en france pour en parler
faire un focus notamment sur le
département des yvelines françois pagé
est avec nos bonsoir vous êtes le
délégué départemental du secours
catholique des yvelines alors plus d'un
million trois cent soixante mille
personnes accueillies par l'association
sas et en france en globalité 27000 ont
été accompagnés en 2017 dans les
yvelines
il ya des personnes de plus en plus dans
le besoin entre page eh oui le besoin se
répand la précarité progressent et la
précarité progresse partout elle n'est
plus que concentré dans quelques villes
elle se répand maintenant dans
l'ensemble du département
plus personne n'est à l'abri d'un
accident de la vie et donc on a maladie
emploi chômage un accident tout
simplement et puis d'un seul coup on
n'arrive plus à s'en sortir des
personnes ou des foyers qui étaient en
situation
de vie normale d'un seul coup décroche
et se trouve à venir dans nos accueils
quel est l'objectif de ce rapport qui
est annuel c'est d'alerter finalement
les pouvoirs publics sur ce problème de
l'avortement d'alerter les pouvoirs
publics sur cette situation de la
précarité est aussi le grand public le
les pouvoirs publics le ministère de la
solidarité lui même dit que 65% des
français trouvent que les pouvoirs
publics ne font pas assez pour la
précarité notre observation c'est que
nous avons besoin de la mobilisation de
tous non seulement des pouvoirs publics
qui dans leurs prérogatives même d'un
certain nombre d'actions mais aussi le
grand public pour être sensibilisés
comprendre connaître mais justement dans
un clip de sensibilisation le secours
catholique a renommé la devise nationale
en disant liberté égalité précarité vous
avez l'impression que ces personnes dans
le besoin sont sont abandonnés par
l'état
non elle n'est elle non pas l'impression
d'être prêt d'être abandonné mais ce que
nous voyons c'est que la première
demande en france des personnes en
précarité c'est un lieu d'accueil lieu
d' écoute un lieu de conseil
avant même toute forme des de matériel
ou dead administratives et donc c'est la
preuve que ce besoin il est présent dans
l'ensemble des personnes et ils ne le
trouvent pas forcément dans
l'administration même si elle reconnaît
sans majorité qu'elles ont un bon
accueil auprès des pouvoirs publics
mais cette dimension d'avoir du temps de
la rencontre et est absolument
aujourd'hui insuffisant dans leurs
propositions qu'elles reçoivent les
vingt-sept mille personnes accueillies
en 2017 par le secours catholique des
yvelines beaucoup de femmes on va y
revenir juste après quel est le profil
de ces personnes sur l'âge est ce que
c'est plutôt des jeunes plutôt des
seniors qui viennent il ya une grande
différence entre les publics d'origine
étrangère ou française
la majorité des étrangers sont des
hommes jeunes
quand la majorité des français sont des
femmes plutôt plus âgés et donc dans les
yvelines
nous sommes en phase de situation de
deux situations très différentes des
jeunes femmes moins de 40 ans 80% des
cas elles ont des enfants elle c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure elle était
en situation de famille
couple un accident de la vie et elle se
retrouve en difficulté et puis de ce
sont des personnes qui sont en
difficulté parce que c'est 70% des
familles ou des personnes que nous
rencontrons les femmes dans deux tiers
des cas elles sont toutes seules
donc soit mères seules soient des femmes
seules et elles sont dans l'ensemble du
département
ça c'est notre notre observation que
l'on soit en ville ou en zone rurale
l'ensemble du territoire est concerné
vous l'avez dit 70% des cas rencontrés
par le secours catholique des yvelines
concerne les femmes c'est une situation
vraiment préoccupante pour les femmes
oui pour nous c'est préoccupant viennent
dans nos accueils des personnes qui
n'étaient pas dans nos profil habituel
dans les personnes que l'on rencontrait
dans nos accueils et nous voyons arriver
des personnes qui étaient en situation
moyenne ordinaire et puis un accident de
la vie je vous le disais tout à l'heure
imprévu et puis d'un seul coup on
n'arrive plus à faire à s'en sortir on
est en difficulté on a besoin d'un
soutien et donc on vient dans une
association un accueil pour chercher du
réconfort du confort ou du soutien pour
rebondir
vous l'avez dit également beaucoup de
ces femmes sont des mères qui élèvent
leurs enfants seuls c'est là c'est la
grande réalité ces enfants sont en
général scolarisés tout se passe bien
pour eux il n'empêche que c'est plus
compliqué d'élever un enfant seule que
quand on est en couple et 28,6 pour cent
des femmes que vous accueillez sont
isolés est ce que si ça c'est
préoccupant
qu'elle soit et c'est préoccupant parce
que c'est plus difficile d'avoir une vie
personnelle d'avoir une vie de loisirs
d'avoir aussi du temps pour rechercher
un emploi si on en a pas vous pourrez
exercer son emploi et donc être relié à
d'autres êtres dans un réseau est
essentielle pour pouvoir bien vivre sa
vie d'adulte ça de vie d'homme ou de
femme et cette précarité du coup elle
devient effectivement nous rencontrer
dans nos accueils du coup aujourd'hui
quelle solution apporte le secours
catholique alors je sais pas si on peut
parler de solution en tout cas quel
accompagnement le secours catholique
apporte-t-il à ces personnes dans le
besoin alors notre premier accueil
c'est effectivement cette dimension
d'être reçus quelle que soit sa
situation d'être accueillis
de pouvoir être écouté avoir du temps et
puis notre deuxième action c'est une
action d'accompagnement vous l'avais dit
à l'instant dans la durée que ce soit un
accompagnement moral financier
administratif familiale cet
accompagnement nous en sommes témoins
produit des merveilles
certes il ya des personnes qui arrivent
à remonter l'escalier social à retrouver
confiance en eux à retrouver confiance
dans la vie dans les relations avec les
autres aux rues entreprendre des
démarches pour l'emploi pour leurs
logements pour faire valoir leurs droits
des personnes qui s'étaient isolés qui
s'était coupé de la société
aujourd'hui elle retrouve capacité à
entrer en relation elle retrouve delà du
confort finalement pour pouvoir entrer
de la sécurité pour pouvoir entrer en
relation avec les autres et du coup se
proposer pour un emploi pour une action
et beaucoup finalement s'investissent
dans nos activités comme contributeurs
comme acteur finalement du secours
catholique
ce passage au sein du secours catholique
peut être un tournant un véritable
tournant dans la vie de ces familles un
véritable tournant un rebond
un changement très important nous sommes
parfois témoins de magnifiques et
histoire qui nous sont rapportés voilà
c'est aussi se réjouir avec elle
et puis les laisser mener leur vie
continue et de les rencontrer
régulièrement ou perdre perdre contact
parce qu'elles ont une autre vie qui
s'ouvre et accueillir d'autres qui
seront en difficulté à ce moment là
dernière chose comment travaillez vous
vous équipe dans les vignes il ya
différents groupes locaux du secours
catholique répartis sur le bassin de huy
60 60 équipes dans l'ensemble du
département une douzaine depuis six pour
saint quentin en yvelines donc des
équipes qui mènent des activités très
différentes de l'apprentissage du
français à l'accueil on l'a vu à
l'accompagnement scolaire ou de
l'hébergement solidaire chez des
particuliers
nous avons des formules de l'activité de
loisir pour permettre des ateliers
créatifs
on peut être en difficulté et avoir de
très grande capacité pour construire
pour produire pour créer de belles
oeuvres d'art et on a fait avoir retenu
le mois dernier une très belle
exposition de leurs oeuvres d'art
franchement c'est rendre hommage aussi à
leurs activités et à leur ténacité parce
qu'elles ont de la capacité de traverser
des difficultés et pour avoir plus
d'informations sur les actions du
secours catholique aussi aider le
secours catholique pourquoi pas rendez
vous sur le site internet qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci françois paget
merci a été avec nous délégué
départemental du secours catholique des
yvelines les inondations c'est un
phénomène d'ampleur tout récemment dans
le département de l'aude ça a été
également le cas ces dernières années
dans les yvelines des épisodes amené à
se répéter qu'ils connaissent avec un
qui connaissent un surplus
d'intervention pour les secours et les
pompiers des yvelines se forment
régulièrement pour gérer tout type de
situation elle c'était le cas notamment
la semaine dernière dans le val d'oise à
lille de loisirs de cergy-pontoise
mélanie poké a suivi ce stage
non
ces pompiers sont déjà sauveteurs
aquatiques
ils participent à une formation
nationale complémentaire au risque
particulier des inondations ce matin un
niveau tout le temps parce que ça évolue
très vite on voit que l'eau c'est pas
notre élément malgré tout donc c'est
bien de toujours manoeuvrer manoeuvrer
pour être le plus performant possible
on a des techniques précises et puis ce
qui est bien c'est qu'on a plusieurs
départements ensemble donc du coup on
peut échanger avec d'autres départements
les techniques qui sont à portée de pour
l'un et pour l'autre récupérer des
personnes naufragés en danger se créer
une bulle d'air une semaine de stage
théorique et pratique pour 18 pompiers
encadrés par sept formateurs des
compétences nécessaires devant
l'augmentation des inondations le
service départemental d'incendié et de
secours des yvelines a comptabilisé plus
de 24% d'intervention supplémentaire
entre les années 2017 et 2018
le scaphandrier avant et est
principalement engagée dans du secours
subaquatique dans des secours en milieu
de 1 à aujourd'hui avec le développement
récurrents et permanent des inondations
depuis une dizaine d'années on est très
fréquemment engagé en fait sur des
sports d'inondations surface
le sdi 78 organise deux stages nationaux
par an sur la base nautique de cergy
pontoise dans le val d'oise dans les
yvelines 58 pompiers sont spécialisés
répartis sur 30 centres de secours les
inondations aujourd'hui sont un facteur
de risque très important pour les
sapeurs pompiers dans leur engagement
pas et plus les pompiers soient
entraînés et préparés à ce risque
et puis pourront travailler en sécurité
on est là surtout pour appréhender le
risque de faire attention de savoir à
quel moment on pourra s'engager et à
quel moment il ne faudra surtout pas
qu'on s'engage et on essaiera de trouver
un plan b
enfin pour porter assistance aux
personnes qui sont bloqués les
secouristes yvelinois opère aussi en
dehors du département sur l'année 2017
ils ont réalisé 120 interventions
deuxième invité kim a rejoint au plateau
catherine arnaud bonsoir on sera vite là
maire de la commune de
chanteloup-les-vignes deuxième vice
présidente du conseil départemental des
yvelines à l'insertion et à la politique
de la ville merci à d'être avec nous
alors vous venez nous parler de du
lancement de la plateforme john 78 c'est
l'une des initiatives du département
pour mettre en relation employeurs et et
bénéficiaires du rsa le revenu de
solidarité active
c'est pour un rôle
pour vers l'emploi l'occasion on va
avoir l'occasion de la présenter cette
plateforme déjà en préambule l'emploi
c'est une véritable préoccupation du
département des yvelines le département
des yvelines depuis quelques années
s'est mobilisée terriblement pour sa
politique d'insertion et d'emploi
il s'est d'abord mobiliser en créant une
agence activity d'abord avec l'état
agence qui a par exemple remis à
l'emploi 3300 personnes depuis deux ans
et puis derrière ça il se mobilise en
mettant des projets d action des
plateformes puisque en fait tous les
moyens de remettre les bénéficiaires du
rsa au travail font que il retrouve un
parcours de vie don qu'ils se réinsèrent
dans un tissu économique et il retrouve
une réalité dans la société c'est aussi
ça qui nous qui nous importe dans les
yvelines compte environ 22 mille
bénéficiaires du rsa rappelons que c'est
le département qui gère cette allocation
individuel c'est bénéficiant ont
beaucoup de mal à retourner vers
l'emploi
alors ces bénéficiaires sont pour la
plupart des chômeurs de longue durée
lorsqu'ils ont eu un emploi c'est ce
nombre de bénéficiaires du rsa monte
d'une façon dramatique yahoo deux ans
puisque nous avions pratiquement le
risque d'atteindre les 30 mille
bénéficiaires du rsa et c'est
extrêmement important d'autant plus
qu'ils sont essentiellement concentrées
sur deux grosses zones de manque
d'emploi du territoire qui sont d'abord
la seine aval à toute la grande vallée
de la seine et puis le territoire de
saint quentin
donc il faut travailler avec ses publics
pour une remise à l'emploi pour une
remise à l'employabilité c'est le
premier c'est le premier travail de
toutes nos personnels sociale et nos
personnels d'insertion puisqu'on a on a
on a des gens qui sont exclusivement
dans cette dimension de l' approche
sociale et de la proche des associations
et puis c'est aussi essayer de
travailler avec eux quelque chose qui
corresponde pas seulement à ce qu'ils
savaient faire mais à ce qu'ils sont
capables d'apprendre à pas seulement
leurs acquis mais leurs acquis à
acquérir mais c'est aussi tout le
travail sur les compétences
parce que c'est aussi redonner de la
confiance en soi de l'estimant soin de
travailler sur ses compétences et de
l'autre côté les employeurs aussi ont
des difficultés à identifier les bons
profils trouver leurs futurs employés
alors les employeurs
egm activity a signé des conventions
avec environ 300 employeurs façon
grosses entreprises sur les territoires
mais les petites entreprises ont
énormément de mal à trouver à proximité
à proximité pourquoi parce que l'idée
c'est quand même que que l'employé soit
plus proche qu'on rapproche bassin de
vie et bassin d'emploi le plus possible
mais de trouver des gens qui sont qui
ont des compétences qu'ils ont garée de
déployer sur des métiers c'est tout
c'est toute l'idée de job 78 pourquoi
parce que à la fois il ya une lecture le
bénéficiaire du rsa s'inscrit sur un
dispositif en ligne effectivement mais
il est accompagné il ne décrit pas
seulement ce qu'a été ce sont ces
métiers avant ce qu'il sait faire mais
il décrit tout un tas de compétences et
il est l'employeur lui regarde ses
compétences essentiellement parce que on
a bien compris qu'en france on était un
peu des obsessionnels de du diplôme mais
il faut d'abord travailler sur les
compétences et sur l'air sur
l'acquisition des savoirs faire et donc
l'employeur peut avec une proximité
géographique puisque elle une lecture
géographique assez proches notamment sur
sa marche au principe de la
géolocalisation absolument mais ça
marche aussi sur la sécurisation de
l'employeur sur la confiance mise dans
un dispositif
sachant que ces bénéficiaires du rsa
sont connus accompagner et continue à
être accompagnés avant la remise en
relation avec l'entreprise c'est un
devoir du bénéficiaire du rsa de se
mettre dans cette démarche active de
recherche d'emploi mais la bénéficiaire
du rsa a de toute façon parce qu'il
touche à un revenu doit être dans une
démarche active mais une démarche active
tout seul c'est pas toujours facile
et puis et puis sa demande sa demande à
être accompagnés accompagnés par des
gens qui sont un peu un peu empathique
un peu en proximité
et puis surtout bénéficié pendant sa
part nature il n'a pas de réseau et il
n'a pas de sens enfin il ne veut pas
simplement rentrer dans des dispositifs
faut l'accompagner mais là on croit
beaucoup en plus de travailler contre
cette lutte contre l'électronique parce
que ça permet aussi de travailler une
plateforme qui est une plateforme
numérique sur lesquels on peut acquérir
aussi le savoir-faire
ça permet aussi de se rassurer 2
dédramatiser lorsqu'on voit que des
emplois dans une proximité géographique
assez importante
eh bien on est déjà rassuré c'est pas du
tout la même chose que de lire un
certain nombre d'offres d'emploi et puis
surtout c'est de redonner confiance aux
entreprises sur les bénéficiaires du rsa
qu'on propose parce qu'ils ont déjà une
espèce de sélection de savoir faire est
d'être dans une démarche locale trouver
un emploi non loin de chez free ces deux
forcément prendre sa voiture
les yvelines c'est un territoire
extrêmement vaste l'idée c'est aussi que
le travail sur le plus proche de la vie
on rappelle juste pour être précis
auprès de nos téléspectateurs vous
parliez de lagence activité celle agence
d'insertion pardon du département des
yvelines juste côté pratique comment en
commande s'inscrit concrètement alors a
été ouverte en septembre pour les
bénéficiaires du rsa qui sont
accompagnés et inscrit donc c'est d'une
montée en charge les entreprises démarre
théoriquement début novembre je crois
qu'elles ont démarré après il ya
effectivement tout le personnel
d'accompagnement qui démarre aussi il va
y avoir une capacité à faire ça deux son
smartphone parce que tous les
bénéficiaires du rsa non pas un
ordinateur mais ils peuvent de toute
façon est accompagnée et puis et puis
voilà c'est une montée en charge
le département des yvelines commence
mais on sait que le département du 92 va
se lancer sur la même application
ce qu'on a aussi de la proximité il faut
aussi pouvoir travailler faire traverser
des des 318 il faut déjà pouvoir ainsi
traverser et puis c'est sans doute une
occasion de trouver l'emploi le plus
proche de chez soi qui pourrait
correspondre à ses compétences mais pour
se rendre sur cette plateforme l'adresse
le site internet jobs soit 118 qui s'est
affichée tout au long de cet entretien
un dernier mot juste sur les objectifs
voilà qu'est ce qui ferait que ça soit
une réussite pour vous cette plateforme
qu'est ce que vous en attendez à l'objet
nommé risée de toute façon retrouvé de
l'emploi pour les minimes bénéficiaires
du rsa c'est pas c'est pas 100 200 300
je veux dire c'est pas ça l'objectif
on s'était pas donné d'objectif avec
activity néanmoins on a accompagné 6500
personnes on a remis à l'emploi 3300
personnes
c'est aussi le travail sur des nouvelles
filières donc c'est tout le travail de
l'emploi à venir avec les entreprises
parce que ça aussi ça permet de
l'anticipation
de toute façon je pense qu'à partir du
moment où on aura mis entreprises et
bénéficiaires du rsa en relation déjà ce
sont des réussites individuelles que
nous allons que nous allons fabriquer
merci catherine arnaud d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes la
deuxième vice-présidente du conseil à
départementale des yvelines à
l'insertion et la politique de la ville
merci actualité littéraire à présent ce
lycéen de la plaine de neuf attrapés
dans le jury du goncourt des lycéens
aboubakar au caf et la chimie a été
choisi pour représenter l'île de france
au sein des jurés du concours de
littérature il va se rendre à rennes
pour participer à la délibération
nationale entre les cinq derniers livres
en lice le nom du lauréat du goncourt
des lycéens sera révélé ce jeudi lors
d'une cérémonie à l'elysée à voisins le
bretonneux les livres ont investi la
dernière cabine téléphonique de la
commune située près de la poste elle a
été déplacée dans le jardin eugène
fleuret à ne fonctionnant plus cette
cabine connaît désormais une deuxième
vie comme boîte à livres sorte de
bibliothèque participative
on peut y déposer des ouvrages ou en
emprunter à la municipalité pourrait en
installer d'autres sur son territoire
après 18 mois de travaux la nouvelle
école de musique d'elancourt a accueilli
ses premiers
des locaux de 900 m² situé dans le
quartier est de 17 mar reportage de
marie line iapichino les nouveaux locaux
de l'école de musique tellancourt son
enfant les 670 élèves ont pu passer de
la maison cartier partager avec d'autres
associations à ce bâtiment dont
l'acoustique des salles a été
particulièrement étudié la halle et le
bâtiment est 100% dédié à eux chaque
salle et adapter le matériel est en
place dès qu'ils arrivent pas de perte
de temps
tout de suite on peut s'exprimer ils
peuvent repartir et ainsi de suite
d'un point de vue architectural les
briques de l'ancien centre oecuménique
ont été conservés il retrouve l'esprit
du temps par son éclairage
c'est là où vous voyez toutes les
parties à jouer qui dans la journée
laisse entrer la lumière naturelle dans
le bâtiment et qui la nuit va permettre
d' illuminé le bâtiment par l'éclairage
interne du violon classique aux
instruments numériques très sale
différentes vont permettre des pratiques
variées pour les représentations un
auditorium a également été installée la
ville d'elancourt ce fait faire grandir
cette école de musique qui propose déjà
l'apprentissage de 24 instruments donc
on essaiera bien entrer dans les années
à venir de procéder à une augmentation
de la fréquentation
ce qui va de pair avec un autre projet
que nous avons qui la municipalisation
d'écoles de musique
cette nouvelle école de musique rentrer
dans une stratégie globale de
redynamiser le quartier 17 mar entre
activités commerciales et culturelles à
notre petit tour des cinémas saint
quentinois avant de se quitter direction
à ce soir le grenier à sel à trappes
avec patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
attrape du 19 au 24 novembre l'éducation
est mise en avant
c'est à l'occasion de la signature du
projet éducatif de territoire que la
ville
promeut tout ce qui est fait en termes
d'éducation donc il ya des ateliers des
projections des rencontres et au cinéma
le grenier à sel
il y aura le vendredi 23 novembre à
20h45 la projection d'un documentaire
qui s'appelle une idée folle qui pose la
question du rôle de l'école 21e siècle à
travers le témoignage d'enseignants
d'enfants de parents ainsi que d'experts
de l'éducation la réalisatrice viendra
donc vendredi 23 novembre à beautor 45
au cinéma le grenier à sel tous nos
déchets racontent inouïe des plus il
reste va on est mais là dedans il a déjà
deux melons des melons d'orage de de
fruits on leur apprend à être pour être
dans la construction pas être contre à
toujours se plaindre tout leur me dit
que mon dieu c'est horrible tout ce qui
m'arrive et ça va pas non mais qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour que ça bouge
tienne citoyenneté en action
et puis quand on sera plus grands on
sera plus des petites choses mais on
fera des grandes choses d'une plus
grande pour essayer de plus changé c'est
la fin de ce journal à suivre un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat sur la thématique
des prix des carburants et de la
mobilisation samedi et des gilets jaunes
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]